these are the new iPhones the iphone 6
and the iphone 6 plus they are without a
doubt the best iPhones we've ever done
and if you don't know here's their sizes
4.7 inch for iphone 6 5.5 inches for
iphone 6 plus but here's the real magic
iphone 6 it's a six point nine
millimeters thin compared to 7.6 for the
5s and boy are they packed with pixels
the iphone 6 plus 1920 x 1080 and we
took special advantage of the iphone 6
plus because of all those pixels to do
some new things with our apps so for
example the messages app now has a new
horizontal to up display next the chip
inside a new generation chip the Apple
a8 stuff to 50 times faster than the
original iphone the iphone 6 and the
iphone 6 plus have equal or better
battery life in every metric than the
iphone 5s the iphone 6 plus 80 hours of
music listening 14 hours of HD video
playback there are new cases for both
phones iphone 6 comes in these three
beautiful colors gold silver and Space
Gray would start to just 199 iphone 6
bus starts at just 2 99 we're going to
start to ship them on September 19 be
able to pre-order them starting this
Friday of course is also the new iOS 8
all these customers will be able to
download for free iOS 8 on September 17
and now I'd like to talk about an
entirely new category of service we call
it Apple pay
we're starting in the US with credit
cards and debit cards from the three
major networks we've been working with
some of the largest retailers to enable
Apple pay in all of their locations
we're not quite finished yet we have one
more thing and here it is Apple watch is
the most personal device we've ever
created it's incredibly customizable and
it works seamlessly with iPhone we
placed extra functionality in a
mechanism that's been on the watch for
decades it's this dial when you turn the
digital crown it zooms in and out we've
designed a range of which faces
we have designed six different straps
from different cases and straps we've
actually created three distinct
collections Apple watch starts at only
three hundred and forty nine dollars and
it will be available early next year